[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans l'entretien
sur France 24 notre invité aujourd'hui
le procureur en chef de la Cour pénale
internationale Karim Kahn il est avec
nous depuis la haie merci d'être avec
nous
merci de m'avoir invité mais c'est
Monsieur Cannes vous revenez tout juste
Conakry la capitale de Guinée et ce
mercredi vous avez pris part la première
journée d'un procès très symbolique
celui du massacre du stade de Conakry il
y a exactement 13 ans plus de 150
personnes sont morts des milliers ont
été blessés plus de 100 femmes violées
et à la barre il y avait en suspect y
compris Moussa Dadis Camara qui était le
chef de la jante à l'époque à quel point
était important pour vous d'être là je
crois que c'était fondamental
c'est beaucoup trop long pour attendre
la justice
mon bureau a commencé une enquête
préliminaire en 2009 au terme de la loi
guinéenne un ancien président Dadis
Camara et 10 autres personnes ont été
extraits de la prison ont répondu au
juge
du tribunal c'est très important
les victimes ont droit à cette enquête
de la réalité et cette enquête a été
faite selon le droit guinéen et
maintenant des juges indépendants vont
déterminer s'il y a une responsabilité
réelle et pour ce processus le CPI s'y
intéresse depuis 13 ans mais pourquoi la
CPI est-elle impliquée vous l'avez dit
vous-même ce sont des procédures
guinéennes donc les gens se demandent
ils connaissent la Cour pénale
internationale c'est procès à la haie et
tout ça qu'est-ce que vous faisiez
là-bas
dans ce pays avait compétence car la
Guinée est une partie étatique et chaque
État est responsable de cette enquête de
poursuite des crimes internationaux dans
le bureau a lancé une enquête et car il
avait compétence concernant ses actions
il s'agissait d'examiner ce qui s'était
passé
avec cette compétence et en 2011 le
bureau a décidé qu'il avait compétence
et qu'il avait suffisamment de raison
pour lancer cette enquête donc il s'agit
du principe de complémentarité
le lancement du
procès nous avons signé un mémorandum
avec le président
intérimaire de l'autorité de transition
et là la Guinée s'engager
à soutenir
ce processus de ne pas s'immiscer
dans cette procédure judiciaire de
partager la formation avec mon bureau
pour s'assurer qu'il y ait une bonne
procédure qui ne soit pas un simulacre
qui ne protège pas les accusés mais au
terme de la loi guinéenne c'est toujours
mieux que ça soit jugé dans le pays
et c'est le droit guinéen qui doivent
fonctionner non seulement concernant les
accusations du 28 septembre 2009 et pour
beaucoup d'autres questions donc je suis
assez pays Simon bureau peut soutenir ça
nous allons faire mais nous allons
rester vigilant et je l'ai dit
clairement président après qu'on ait
signé ce mémorandum
étant donné que le procès va commencer
j'ai arrêté cette enquête mais si ce
processus se poursuit pas et ne présente
pas les éléments d'intégrité
indépendance que l'on attend que l'on
exige je pourrais réouvrir cette enquête
donc c'est une collaboration c'est un
processus de collaboration qui
représente le fondement essentiel de ce
système basé sur des règles et si un
État prend ses responsabilités je serai
le premier à l'applaudir comme
j'applaudis
le président intérimaire de Guinée qui
s'est assuré qu'il y ait de l'espace
pour l'État de droit oui alors vous
parlez de ce même arendum vous dites que
ça donne certaines garanties que le
process sera juste et transparent mais
il y a quand même cette image de vous
côte à côte avec un homme en treillis un
homme qui a pris le pouvoir à travers un
coup d'état dont le pays est sous
sanction internationale les
manifestations sont interdits
l'opposition en exil ou en prison donc
évidemment il y a un risque d'être
utilisé politiquement
parce qu'il y a un riche qu'il faut agir
je ne cherche pas à changer les régimes
j'ai conclu un amant eu un mémorandum
lorsque je suis intervenu en Colombie
une situation qui pourrissait puis 17
ans quand j'ai lancé une enquête au
Venezuela avec le président Maduro dans
son palais présidentiel j'ai aussi signé
à mes mandats je viens de le faire il y
a deux trois jours en Guinée donc je
l'ai dit à plusieurs reprises je ne
cherche pas changer de régime ça ne fait
pas partie de mon mandat et en tant que
magistrat en tant que procureur de la
CPI je ne veux pas chercher à savoir si
un régime est marxiste ou libéral ou
démocratique ou autoritaire ou
militaires simplement je me concentre
sur une question est-ce qu'il y a
impunité pour des crimes qui ont été
commis dans le cadre de la compétence de
la Cour et le gouvernement intérimaire a
mis en place ce procès à sortir les gens
de prison ils ont présenté les accusés
devant les victimes je viens de
rencontrer hier où il y a deux jours les
avocats de des victimes les avocats de
la défense c'est un moment très
important
il faut montrer que nous ne sommes pas
politiques nous sommes prêts à parler à
tout le monde à tout gouvernement
sérieux et prêt à affronter cette
responsabilité internationale il faut
pas qu'il y ait de refuge pour le
génocide les crimes contre l'humanité
les crimes de guerre ou les crèmes
d'agression dans le cadre de notre
compétence
clarification à propos de ce mémé random
vous sembliez indiqué que oui bien sûr
il y a le procès du massacre mais que
cela veut aussi dire qu'il pourrait y
avoir des procédures pour d'autres cas
parce que hélas la Guinée a connu
beaucoup de violence et de crimes
qu'est-ce qu'on voit
quels sont les problèmes qu'on a examiné
parce que ce sont des accusations
terrifiantes concernant le 28 septembre
2009 et puis ensuite il y a eu des
accusations de viol de violences
sexuelles de gens brûlés torturés
des gens ont été ont comparer devant le
tribunal c'est important mais en fait
quand un système indigène autochtone
mûri il peut utiliser tout l'arsenal des
garanties offertes par la Constitution
dans un système basé sur des règles donc
oui nous regardons ce qui s'est passé le
28 septembre mais en fait je l'ai dit le
Président si les racines de la justice
peuvent être davantage enracinés
cultivées chez eux si on peut travailler
avec la communauté internationale
l'Union européenne la Guinée beaucoup
d'autres pays ainsi que la CPI les
nations inu participent si ensemble on
peut soutenir la Guinée mais la Guinée
elle doit prendre ses responsabilités je
n'aurais aucun remord je serais ravi de
m'éclipser laisser l'enquête
préliminaire passer du partenariat et du
soutien à une position de vigilance pour
s'assurer que ça ne soit pas une comédie
que ce ne soit pas une opération en
surface et qu'on affronte véritablement
la vérité et que ces victimes qui ont
tant souffert puissent avoir accès à la
justice parce qu'elle y en droit je veux
maintenant parler un petit peu
rapidement de l'Ukraine dans le nord-est
du pays dans la ville d'izum une fosse
commune à asse semble-t-il été trouvé
vous avez dit au de sécurité des Nations
unies que une équipe de votre bureau
aller retourner là-bas pour trouver des
preuves est-ce qu'elle est là est-ce
qu'elle a accès mais plus largement
est-ce que vous voyez de plus en plus de
preuves de crime commis en Ukraine par
la Russie ou peut-être par d'autres
oui tout à fait nous avons une équipe
sur le terrain qui travaille
continuellement depuis mai et nous avons
une excellente partenariat avec les
experts scientifiques de mon bureau mais
aussi d'autres États tels que la
Belgique et les Pays-Bas et bien sûr ils
se sont des accusations graves qui ont
été faites
et nous parlons autorités ukrainiennes
j'ai essayé de parler à la Fédération
russe et maintenant il s'agit pour nous
de est-ce que les Russes vous répondent
malheureusement pas pour le moment mais
je continuerai de revenir à la charge
parce que je crois que c'est dans
l'intérêt de tout le monde s'il y a une
vérité le processus judiciaire la
dévoilera et s'il y a des mensonges ils
ne peuvent pas être dissimulés s'il y a
ce processus judiciaire indépendant et
tout parti tout ONG tout particulier
devrait pouvoir partager des
informations
vous êtes dans la confiance et dans le
secret avec mon bureau pour que Dieu si
Dieu le veut nous puissions nous
s'assurer que ces éléments de preuve
sont fiables que nous utiliserons pour
parvenir des résultats et puis on
soumettra ces résultats à des juges
indépendants qui vont les examiner en
effectuant leur rôle propre c'est à dire
une garantie de qualité nous faisons
notre travail il s'agit d'un détachement
scientifique et objectif le ministre
russe des Affaires étrangères Serguey
lavrof a dit au Conseil de sécurité des
Nations unies que la CPI ne réagissait
pas au crime commis par l'Ukraine et que
donc il n'avait plus confiance en la
cour alors d'abord une réponse de votre
part et ensuite est-ce que vous enquêtez
sur de possibles crimes par l'Ukraine
je l'ai dit très publiquement j'étais à
Cox bazar au Bangladesh
le 24 février le 25 j'ai fait ma
première déclaration j'ai souligné que
toutes les parties au conflits ont des
responsabilités très claires je les dis
à de nombreuses reprises quand j'ai
parlé aux Ukrainiens à la collectivité
internationale et aussi la Fédération
russe la question c'est que toute partie
peut dire qu'elle a confiance ou pas
confiance ça dépend de mais s'ils ont
des informations qui les partagent avec
mon bureau
mais il pourrait faire mieux que de dire
que nous ne faisons pas dans quête sur
ces informations que les parties au
Confluences ne sont pas prêts les
partager avec une cour indépendante
impartiale une cour que le Conseil de
sécurité utilisé au moins deux fois en
Libye au soudain et j'invite tout
simplement tout est à partie ou même
tout est partie la Russie l'Ukraine a
partagé leur information avec nous nous
avons une bonne coopération avec
l'Ukraine et j'espère que l'on pourra
commencer à coopérer avec la Fédération
russe je continuerai d'essayer de les
contacter leur dire nous n'avons pas
l'objectif politique nous voulons
découvrir la vérité s'ils ont des
informations qui considèrent être la
vérité je suis sûr qu'il a partageront
avec nous mais je n'ai pas cette
information pour le moment Karim kan
merci beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité
sur France 24 merci à vous d'avoir suivi
cet entretien rester sur nos antennes
pour plus d'informations
[Musique]